Thank you.
Okay, I'd like to go ahead and just inform everybody on the committee as what's up or what's down today.
For those that were here yesterday, I think most of us were here, that we had the governor present his budget, and within the budget he addressed certain topics within education.
As you may recall, he mentioned the base adequacy, which is being jumped by about $1,000.
When you look at that in terms of where we're going, that's going to increase base adequacy by $150 million.
He also looked at the F&R, free and reduced category of differentiated aid, and jumped that by $20 million.
We've also looked at the weighted version for special education within differentiated aid and jumped that by about $20 million, from $63 to $83 million.
We're talking now stabilization.
That's $150 million.
Stabilization built on this formula that we have or stabilization built on something that we have not yet seen.
I spent a lot of time this morning over with LBA, and they do not yet have a spreadsheet which shows how this money sorts out in terms of local school districts.
That's going to maybe be presented by the department this morning at 10 o'clock.
And so we have three remaining bills that are early bills that have to be gotten out.
For 272, that's the funding for the charter public school.
The governor's budget certainly implicates that as well.
It's all tied together.
492, that one we can do, that was the bill which we dealt with the statutory books that we are all anxious in receiving and having possession of.
And 529, which deals with the whole nine yards as far as, you know, the formula from fiscal capacity disparity aid to relief aid to extraordinary needs grants.
And there are a lot of implications associated with that.
We cannot take any action in here, at least I can't, until I have a better understanding of what's going on with the governor's budget and where we stand.
And it implicates some of our policymaking, decision-making.
There's a lot of results that can occur from this, and I don't want to get into that right now, which would cause a lot of angst on the floor from various folks.
So we need to really shoot our policy where we are to finance and really state some of the needs.
So we will be taking a recess at 10 o'clock.
Going down.
to finance and really state some of the needs.
So we will be taking a recess at 10 o'clock, going down to finance.
Those who want to, I for sure, and I know Representative Luna for sure, Representative Cordelli, and Representative Myler will be there.
Then we're going to come back and open up the exec session.
So we're just going to recess it, open it up right after lunch.
We have to have this report done today.
And so we're coming right down to the line here.
So what I'd like to do is looking at that list of bills which we have for exacting today.
See, tomorrow we can't exact right off because we have scheduled from nine o'clock to 11 30 hearings and that's in the calendar and then we would have we could exact in the afternoon but that we've missed the deadline so the only way we're going to be able to exact these bills and do it properly other than retaining them and and I don't have an inclination to want to retain them, we're going to have to do it today, these two bills I'm speaking of.
So there's going to be a lot of good, healthy discussion here today after in the noontime.
So what I'd like to do right now is open up the executive session for 492.
492, would everybody please open your, um, I think we're fairly familiar with this bill.
We tried to execute once before and did it not to be addressing the early bills first.
Of the 16 early bills, maybe 17, the 492 and the other two are the only remaining bills.
492 first?
Yes, that's the amendment.
Okay.
If there are any amendments for 492 and 492 is requiring the Department of Education to provide the House and Senate Standing Committee's response for education with copies of the laws and rules relative to education.
The yellow books, the green books, that's what we're after here.
So let's open this up to discussion purposes right now.
And on behalf of Representative Tanner, Representative Lunell, you're recognized to explain what's in front of us.
thank you very much um mr chair so um so i think everybody's familiar with house bill 492 which would require the department to provide uh house and senate education committees copies of the um everybody knows what So we're talking about the law books that pertain to education.
There's an amendment that Representative Tanner prepared, I think in coordination with Representative Ladd.
And what does it clarify?
It actually replaces the bill.
So it removes the last sentence from the bill that says member of the House of Representatives so it just strictly relates to the department making these books available to the two education states.
And superintendents.
Okay.
Is there any?
That's amendment number 2023-01520.
Yeah.
So we're in the discussion.
Is there any discussion on that right now amongst committee members here?
Representative Woodcock.
Just a question, David.
Yeah.
Representative Luno.
I'm sorry, an executive session.
Yeah.
We've been reminded to use, you know, formal.
I'll accept the question from Representative Luno.
Representative Woodcock calling.
On the amendment, it says 60 days after passage.
And we want a date in there because we're already done for this year?
No, because this still has a long way to go.
It's got to go to the House floor.
Then it goes to the Senate.
Actually, it will go to House floor.
Then it will go to Finance.
And then it will go to House 4 again, and then it will go to the Senate.
It may have a scenic tour through the Senate, and by the time it gets to the governor's desk, you're familiar with Schoolhouse Rock?
Thank you, Chairman.
All right.
You're welcome.
Further discussion?
I'll second the end.
Well, we don't have a motion more discussion right now represent damon thank you mr chair um i have two things i have lind representative tanner's uh remarks from when she introduced the bill which i could perhaps review and summarize and then i'd also like to just state my vigorous support for this.
So is that okay if I just use some bullets from Linda's?
So Linda noted she's in, sorry, Representative Tanner, in her fifth term in the House, her fourth term on House education.
And in the first three of those four terms, this book was readily provided.
And as most of us who have looked at it know, includes the full text of Title 15 education laws and amendments enacted by the general court in the last session so every edition is updated from what has previously happened.
I'm going to just read this paragraph from Representative Tanner.
My educational background and career has been in education, not law.
I was honored and excited to be chosen to serve on house education.
I feel my experience and knowledge of education is an important resource for this committee work.
While teaching, I often questioned and sometimes subjected to the regulations and rules handed down from the state.
As a representative, I am now aware of how those rules and regulations are formulated and enacted with more understanding, but not without frustration of the lack of connection between what is happening in our schools and what we legislate.
Having information is essential to our job from listening to the people who are providing the services and education to having an understanding of the current laws and how they are applied.
As a lawmaker on the Education Committee, I was and still am intimidated by the complexity of language structure and procedures of working in the world of laws, education statutes, and administrative rules.
I appreciate the tutorials from the Department of Education on certain topics like funding, but being able to have the annotated law book gives me the opportunity to look through the many education statutes, gain insight to the changes in those laws, and see some of the court opinions.
For example, I might look at the whole chapter on charter schools and see references to other statutes in other sections.
I can see opinions, amendments, and how particular laws had changed and when.
There are court opinions cited that give context to the law.
The current website just doesn't give me that information or ability to look at parts of the education laws, both as a general overview or a specific session.
As someone unfamiliar with the practice of law, I find this book invaluable.
There are more remarks, but I think that is adequate.
The point that Representative Tanner is making, and I absolutely agree, is that I've many times gone to the web and looked at the links, and I see the statute as it's written.
But I don't see the background information that's relating to that.
For example, if I'm going to funding and I want to know more about these Claremont decisions or the Londonderry decision or other such and how they apply to our constitution and apply to our funding, that's there in the annotated version, but it's not on the web.
And when you're writing legislation, it's always wise to get as much information as you can.
when we're writing legislation oftentimes we're doing that in in summer months and and and when we can't get that information out of out of here because things are closed down pretty much and you're not down here to begin with so i i i concur that we need to have the annotated version we need it in hard copy and we need to have that available to us when we want to research what's basically was the original you know law that supported this and perhaps some of that intent which we can take from you know court findings so that's my my take on this as well there is a cost to it but there's a you know know, we get paid, what, $100 a year?
Yeah, I think we don't get a computer.
We don't get all that other.
And here we are now trying to make decisions based upon, let's have the annotated version.
So is there any other discussion on this?
Yes, Representative Belcher.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
With some of what was just brought up brought something to mind as far as I'm trying to understand why we're looking to the executive branch to be doing this instead of perhaps trying to even provide funding if necessary to our own branch to bring somebody in to do this.
Because it seems to me there could be a potential conflict of separation of powers if we're asking the executive branch to essentially provide us with information that would help explain our jobs to us in terms of how these legal precedents apply.
The executive branch, i.e.
the OLS, are the ones providing us the books.
Now as far as you want to track it back as far as who pays for the books, the state is going to be paying for it.
Whether it's coming out of the DOE budget or it's going to come out of another line.
But these books that we got right here, the green ones, are a result of ours saying we want them, and all of a sudden the box of the green books was found in a room, and we had them.
So I think we need to have it in statute where this is provided, and when somebody comes on new here on this committee, it's provided so they can see what they're walking into, especially in the area of education.
That's further discussion.
Okay, so what we need now is to have a motion made represent cordell you want to make it uh thank you minister uh chair i would move uh ought to pass on amendment 2023 0151h and i'll second that okay is there any further discussion on this?
Madam Clerk?
Vice Chairman Cordelli.
Yes.
Representative Luckes.
Representative Ford.
Yes.
Representative Belcher.
No.
Representative Dry.
Yes.
Representative McDonald.
Representative Noble.
Yes.
Representative Petternell.
Representative Cortiello.
Yes.
Representative Myler.
Representative Cornell.
Yes Yes Representative Lane Yes Representative Luno Yes Representative Ellison Yes Representative Woodcock Yes Representative Hall Yes Representative Balboni Yes Representative Cascadden Yes Representative Damon Yes, please Chairman Lett Yes 19 yays, 1 nay Thank you Thank you.
yes please chairman lead yes 19 yeas one nay thank you okay now represent cornelli thank you i would like to move ought to pass as amended on house bill 492 fn i'll second that and that we have a second made motion made by represent cordelli second by no second was made by represent luno and this is in regard to uh requiring the department of education to provide the house and senate standing committees responsible for education with copies of the laws and rules relative to education and this is as amended with 0151H.
Further discussion?
Not seeing any?
Madam Clerk?
Representative Vice Chairman Cordelli.
Yes.
Representative Lekas.
Representative Ford.
Yes.
Representative Belcher.
No.
Representative Dry.
Yes.
Representative McDonald.
Representative Noble.
Yes.
Representative Petternell.
Representative Coratiela.
Yes.
Representative Myler.
Representative Cornell.
Yes.
Representative Lane.
Representative Luna.
Yes.
Representative Ellison.
Representative Woodcock.
Yes.
Representative Hall.
Representative Balboni.
Yes.
Representative Cascadon.
Representative Damon.
Yes.
Chairman Ladd.
19 yays, 1.
That's our.
Let's try to do.
So.
You don't want remember the number.
Yeah.
Let's see for school building.
Oh, that's school building.
Yeah, I don't want going to get bogged up.
For mental health.
Yeah, something we're not going to get bogged up.
Thank you.
For a motion.
Mr.
Chairman.
I would move ought to pass on an in-house bill.
We will go retain on that.
Oh yes, I'm sorry.
I would like to correct myself and make a motion to retain this bill.
And I'll second that.
Thank you.
Do you want to speak to your motion?
Just to say that there is a similar bill in the House, excuse me, in the Senate that some indicate might be better than this one even.
So we can retain this and have this in our back pocket if needed.
I think that certainly justifies holding onto this bill.
With one of the senators over there yesterday, and the one coming at is seen by, I think, the Senate as also a pretty solid bill.
So we may want to wait and keep this one in our pocket as we said that we can retain it if something doesn't happen we can take action on this in november so further discussion is represented with car represent what idea remember that bill i don't have that outside his office downstairs and and I didn't get the number of the bill, but yeah, it's one that he is involved with.
Thank you.
Further discussion?
Madam Clerk?
Motion is to retain 352 made by Representative Cordelli, seconded by Representative Luno.
Vice Chairman Cordelli.
Yes.
Representative Lekas.
Representative Ford.
Yes.
Representative Belcher.
Representative Dry.
Yes.
Representative McDonald.
Representative Noble.
Yes.
Representative Pedernal.
Representative Cordello.
Yes.
Representative McDonald.
Representative Noble.
Yes.
Representative Petternell.
Representative Coritello.
Yes.
Representative Myler.
Representative Cornell.
Yes.
Representative Lane.
Representative Luno.
Yes.
Representative Ellison.
Representative Woodcock.
No.
Representative Hall.
Yes.
Representative Alboney.
Representative Cascadden.
Woukock no representative hall yes representative alboni yes representative cascaddon yes representative Damon no chairman lad yes 18 yeas 2 nays yeah that's one we want to work with finance on and that's the 10 o'clock we're doing 272 and 529.
were there some um bills that even the sponsor recommended like 382.
yeah yeah 382 what's the other one 6 36 and 634.
yeah that's the one where they didn't show up, right?
Yeah.
You want to do those next?
Yeah, we can do those.
ITL?
Yeah.
Which was the latter of the bills?
634.
That's the one.
Nobody showed up, right?
332 I had introduced.
Okay, we're going to look at HB 382 at this point in time.
Pardon me?
382.
I can't hear what you're saying.
Thank you.
This is a bill authorizing local school boards to give students release time for participation in religious instruction in an elective course for the purpose of satisfying curriculum requirements.
And you may recall there was a no-show here on this from the singular crime sponsor.
Is there a motion?
Representative Cordelli.
Thank you.
I'd move ITL.
Second.
And Representative Meiler seconds that.
We have a motion on the floor to ITL 382 made by Representative Cordelli and second by Representative Meiler.
Discussion from Representative Cordelli.
I would just say, despite my fascinating introduction to this bill, I am moving ITL.
Representative Meiler.
Further discussion from the committee.
Representative Belcher.
eccentricity of some of the introduction.
It does appear that this bill is designed to actually bring us into compliance with the Supreme Court ruling that would authorize release for religious instruction that should be applied or should be applicable for credit.
So I do think the bill itself, the effect of the bill would appear to be good, despite some of the perhaps imprecise language in the legislative findings.
Is there further discussion?
Representative Petternell?
I agree with what you're saying.
However, if I have this correct, local school districts decide what credits are some extracurricular credits that might be necessary or different credits other than what's normally required, if I'm saying this right, in order to graduate from high school.
So students might get credit for this, and it wouldn't transfer to another high school should they change schools.
Further discussion?
Yes, Representative Dry.
What's the relation to this to the similar bill that was introduced at the same time?
Are you talking about the other bill that was almost identical?
Yeah.
They're very similar.
Okay.
And what's the status of that one?
We have to act on that as well.
Okay.
Today.
Is there any further discussion on authorizing local school boards to give students release time for participation in religious instruction in an elective for the purpose of satisfying curriculum requirements?
should be noted that curriculum is that of the local school district and the school board.
And what you're telling them curriculum is that of the local school district and the school board.
And what you're telling them now is that this will supersede the responsibility of the school board who is issuing that graduation diploma.
So there is some conflict here on this.
and I just believe that when we're looking at it, we're also talking about the minimum standards of public school approval.
And we get into these areas that we are not the ones which should be dealing with that.
That's a state board issue.
So I also say the intent may be fine, but the outcomes and the results and the causations are the ending results.
We ought to be very careful on where we're going on this.
Mr.
Chair?
Yes.
The fact that this bill gives them authorization only to have release time, it doesn't really authorize the curriculum.
For the purposes of satisfying curriculum requirements.
Representative Lekas.
But it also says the State Board of Education shall adopt and each local Board of Education may implement a policy for the student to do it.
And it says in grades where credit is earned, a student who participates in release time may earn, not shall earn, may earn.
So it's still they can decide whether or not they did or not.
We're just what basically, as Rep.
Ford said, we're just we're saying we're authorizing the release of the student.
but the rest of it it says I mean it's it's talking about the rules time it shall be credited with time spent that's attendance not credit and and they can't be released from a required core curriculum class it's just saying that they can and they're not going to be docked for it.
That's all it's authorizing.
The rest is still the state board, the local school board, etc.
still has precedence over all the other aspects, including granting credits.
It's just saying you're going to let kids be released for this as long as they're not being released out of a, you know, core class, and you can't dock them for, you know, for missed time, which is really, we're the ones that came up with those rules anyways.
Rep.
San Cridelli?
Thank you.
I would just look at line nine on page two and that you're correct that there should be a policy to attend release time as an elective course.
So we're saying it's release time for an elective course that would be provided by someone outside school personnel.
But it is saying it's an elective course is to be granted for this in my reading of it.
Representative Damon.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I have several concerns and I support the ITL motion.
So on the first page of the bill, lines 17 and 18, suggests to me that we already have this covered anyway because it says the United States Constitution and the state law allows local school districts to offer religious least time education for the benefit of public school students.
So it seems to me we already have this.
Secondly, same page, lines 22 to 24.
That is not language that I think belongs in an RSA.
And thirdly, I'm quite concerned.
This is different from a, for example, comparative religion class that could have great merit in a curriculum.
This is saying we will release students for them to receive religious education in their particular belief system.
And I don't think that that belongs during the public school day.
There's plenty of other time for that.
I'm concerned about what these students will be missing when they're off having their catechism or learning the Torah or whatever they're doing.
So I very much support the ITL.
Thank you.
Professor Myler?
I know I was late to this hearing, but the brief notes I have, am I incorrect that the bill's sponsor said that we should ITL this bill?
That's what my notes say.
Is that correct?
I've spoken to the prime sponsor, and that was his wish.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
May I elaborate on that?
Because it was my understanding through the email I received that one of them had wanted ITL so the other identical bill could be heard.
Representative Cordiello?
Yes.
I'd just like a little clarity.
I'm trying to understand this bill.
so if someone could help me with that as far as I'm trying to think of a hypothetical situation in which, for instance, if a student wanted to take a course offered at a Catholic high school, let's say, so this would allow them the time to go do that during the public school day if they went to a public school.
Am I correct on that?
I'm just looking for clarity because there hasn't been a lot of time to do in-depth research.
That's already permissible.
You can do that working with the administration and the buildings.
That does occur.
So that's covered by another law?
Yes, sure it does.
Okay.
So what is the need for this, the hypothetical?
Just any clarity anyone could offer, please.
Representative Pentanel?
I've spoken with the sponsors of each of these bills, and neither one of them wish to move these forward, and I tried to make that happen, but apparently I didn't talk to everybody on the committee.
And one other note there, if you look in the analysis of the bill, the bill requires the State Board of Education to adopt rules.
So there is going to be some expense to all this, and I'm trying to find out where it says in the analysis.
I don't see any mention of the 541A in here.
So there are going to have to be some rules developed.
So I think that the bill does have some sloppiness within it.
The language was pointed out.
But it also doesn't say where the rules have to be made, as far as I haven't found yet.
So if the sponsors indicated that the bill shouldn't go forward, and the sponsor wasn't even here to introduce it, Thank you.
bound yet.
So, and if the sponsors indicated that the bill shouldn't go forward and the sponsor wasn't even here to introduce it, I would think that we would, you know, not, yeah, yeah, support it.
Is there further discussion on this?
Madam Clerk, would you please call the roll?
Vice Chairman Cordelli.
Yes.
Representative Lekas.
Representative Ford.
Yes.
Representative Belcher.
Representative Dry.
Yes.
Representative McDonnell.
Representative Noble.
Yes.
Representative Petternnell.
Representative Cortella.
Yes.
Representative Myler.
Representative Cornell.
Yes.
Representative Lane.
Representative Luna.
Yes.
Representative Ellison.
Representative Woodcock.
Yes.
Representative Hall.
Representative Balboni.
Yes.
Representative Kaskadon.
Representative Damon.
Yes.
Chairman Lett.
20 a's.
Zero nays.
Yes.
We have 634, but we're rolling in here, getting pretty close to this 10 o'clock hearing.
That's really what we have to attend to.
So we can take up the other bill, 634, when we do the other exec sessions, which will probably follow this afternoon.
So what we're going to do is we're going to take a break right now to attend this finance meeting at 10 o'clock and then we'll come back and we will pick this recess up as soon as that completes down there we may have our answers done let's say at 11 o'clock and there's no sense to have to wait to 1 o'clock to pick that up.
So we will pick this back up today upon completion of the education portion of the budget presentation.
So we're in recess.
Big room at the end of the hall.
We all do that.
What to that what we all well you're free to go anywhere you want right now oh no it's why it's necessary if they go and come back and tell us i'll believe what they said we're in recess.
Oh, well, look.
Back to the thought.
Follow the thought of here.
Yeah.
Right here.
Can you pin it?
Okay.
That was some details.
What was the vote?
What was the vote.
Okay.
In consent, I guess.
Oh, yeah, that was never mentioned.
I'm assuming.
Yes.
Okay.
John's not in court.
Thank you, Connie.
You're welcome.
For what?
Oh, you got that.
Okay.
Thank you.
I'd like to go ahead here.
For all those that attended the governor's presentation on finance, there is a lot said, and with that, a lot of work put on the table for us as legislators.
So what I'm going to do right now is that we're going to break for lunch right now, and we're going to come back one hour, which would be WEEK, THE LAST WEEK, come back and we'll get on with it.
A lot of work today, huh?
Thank you.
I'm going to take a few minutes.
I'm going a great deal this morning and yesterday that's got to be taken into account.
So 529 is relative to additional aid grants for schools based on free and reduced price meals and fiscal capacity disparity.
So I'm opening it up to discussion right now.
Are there any amendments available for this particular bill that we should all have?
You want me to address that?
Thank you very much, Mr.
Chair.
We do have a couple of amendments to bring forward.
However, they're still in legislative services right now.
We may have them, certainly hope to have them very shortly, but I could print off a, I could make copies of what legislative services has for draft, make some copies of that, and the finance copier.
That would be helpful.
And then with those we can have some general some general discussion.
Right.
And I'll just sort of speak to it right now.
There are some technical corrections on it.
Added an accountability section based on some discussions I had with the chair.
And although it seemed like the governor this morning was talking about not having an accountability, but whatever, and extending it to both FY24 and FY25, as the governor has done.
And so it's essentially the fiscal capacity disparity aid plus pre- and reduced price lunch enhanced aid.
Total package coming in at about $100 million each year.
And it would obviously go to the school districts and the municipalities that have lower than average equalized property valuation per pupil and higher rates of free and reduced-price lunch students.
But I'll print that off now and be back in a couple minutes.
We're going to do the charter next because I've got to get the amendment to all those.
Yeah, and while we're discussing 529, we will also be discussing 272.
bills bills are dealing with, both are early bills, and they are linked together.
And so we are wanting to discuss that, and seeing we're in executive session, we're discussing both these bills.
If we need to be discussing both interchangeably, we will do so.
So we can get to an answer or a conclusion today, hopefully.
Yes, Representative Lekas.
Would it be allowable at this point to introduce an amendment that has a completely different way of figuring out additional aid grants, but not based on free and reduced price meals and fiscal disparity capacity, or would we have to wait until next year and do it as a new bill?
Because it's still dealing with additional aid grants, just a different way of determining them.
What is the, I don't know what we can and can't do at this point.
At this point in time, we have to address the basic concepts that are within these two bills.
If you have a different process, there's a lot of different ways to be looking at how we're going to be doing all this, and I would suggest that that be done working directly with finance.
I can tell you that I've been in so many meetings.
Just about maybe 10 minutes ago, I walked down the hallway and had a discussion with the chair of finance and the division chairs, and especially Division 2.
If there's going to be any kind of a policy decision that they're going to have to make, they're going to engage this group right here, this committee, before they go forward to HB2.
Now, that's a real give to us.
And so they're really open to communicating and trying to make sure that they can get things done in a way that they're going to have maybe a broad brush type support.
because can i can can i know because i had talked to mark and i'm going to continue talking to mark and the next thing i want is a comparison between uh what are the supposedly poor time i you know based on, right, based on fiscal capacity disparity, based on reduced price meals, and based on Medicaid, because he said they can get us the Medicaid numbers for each town.
And we could use the Medicaid numbers instead of these others to get an idea of poverty in a town.
And that is something they can give us.
And so I'm wondering if that, and I would like to see all three, I mean, if they all correlate, that's awesome.
But if they don't, if they're different, then we got to worry about what represents reality better.
So we're talking about Medicaid direct here now.
No, I was, no.
You're talking about eligibility through Medicaid.
No, no, not that.
Not free and reduced lunch through Medicaid.
Medicaid can't give us that unless we go through the federal government.
Medicaid can give us the number, just the number not attached to people, of how many people in a town are on Medicaid.
It can give us that, and that should be a good indicator of poverty in a town.
And that's what we're looking for, is indicators of poverty in a town.
That's why we have free and reduced price meals.
That's why we're using that.
That's why we have fiscal capacity.
So where you are, you're in a whole different ballgame here as far as discerning how we're going to do this.
We're limited with time right now.
Medicaid is working off the census data, which is oftentimes regional.
and if you came to me and saying, would you go along with that?
The census data for Drafton County is like counties within counties.
I know.
I'm not talking about the census data.
I'm talking about the actual number of people enrolled in Medicaid per town.
They are allowed to give us that information.
They cannot give us who they are, so we can't do the mapping to the students, but they are allowed to give us how many people per town are actually enrolled in Medicaid.
And it seems like that would give us a good indicator of poverty in a town.
So where you are right now, you're using a whole different format.
And we're in the process right now of developing budgets.
It's basically a little late.
You might talk directly with finance on that.
But for us to start changing gears here, we would be building something on data we don't have.
So I will continue getting that data and I will put it before finance then.
Good.
Can I ask a question about 272, Chair Ladd?
Yes.
I know that the increase for the charters, according to 272, brings them up to 5,141, I think.
Do you know the number for what the governor said?
The governor is proposing 4,000 plus for, I'm pulling my book out here, for the adequacy formula, for base adequ.
And taking into account the CPI as well, but each year, but I just want to compare what, what this bill says and what the governor is saying.
He's trying to get the $9,000, I believe.
Total..
The amount of money which base would be is up around four thousand eight hundred dollars.
I'm giving a rough ballpark figure right there.
OK, that's the 20 call it.
Twenty four percent is when I think it's closer to twenty five of so increase.
So if it's $4,800 and we're talking about a number which she has is $5,000-something, adding those together, you're coming over.
I think Representative Cordelli is considering trying to make an amendment for a cost figure which would take it to that nine without going over.
So it means we'd have to reduce some of the money that's allocated in the 272 bill.
Rather than being at the 5,000 something, maybe whatever would be lesser amount.
I can't mention that.
Yes.
My draft ready to submit to OLS reduces the amount that's in the bill of 51 41 by 500 so it would bring the price tag down from um 7.5 million to uh under five is that comparable to what the governor was saying in his budget I don't know how much teachers when I increase funding to charters, I couldn't figure out the amount.
I think that brings it down, Mike.
It's close.
It comes out to about $9.4,000.
I think, I can't swear by it, but I thought he said nine.
But that's something that's by slicing it some, we're sending the message that it has to be in line with the governors.
And that's all we're trying to do today is communicate policy.
policy.
If I may, I think that the goal for these two bills that we're considering is really to get them out of the committee as best, you know, what we feel is appropriate.
But we're really trying to deal with the policy content that then goes to finance, and finance is really the ones that does the final cutting and distributing of the funds within the budget.
So our goal here is what's the policy that we want to go forward to the finance committee so they can do the actual number crunching.
Is that correct, Mr.
Chair?
I think so.
So, Mr.
Chair, if it's the will of the body, I'll send this down to OLS for drafting.
It's just a simple number change, but it would, I think, put it more in line with what the governor was talking about.
Can you recall, anybody recall what the gov did say?
What is it?
Was it?
Yeah, in the bill itself, you'll see on I don't have the line number.
Go to two.
Yes, the charter school 272 online six, the 5141 would be changed to 4627, which is roughly Thank you.
On line six, the 5141 would be changed to 4627, which is roughly $500.
Yes.
Why are you making that reduction?
To be in line with the governor's proposal.
The governor...
Okay, that's the rationale for that.
Yes.
Excuse me?
Okay, thank you.
That's all.
Thank you.
Representative Lekas.
Who?
The numbers person from the DRE.
Mark is...
Thank you, Representative Kiske.
Just to clarify, so by putting in 4627 for charter public schools, is that going to move that more in line on what we want to do for public schools?
I mean, regular public schools?
Is that what you're suggesting to change for?
The bill which we had before us on the 529 doesn't deal with base adequacy at all or differentiated aid where you would see that base cost the governor proposed at that $4,700.
Yeah, roughly.
No, I calculated a little higher than that last night.
I got 4,800 plus.
But because I took a flat 25 percent, what he's doing is he's taking basically about 23 or 20 so, and then he's taking that 2 percent growth.
So in there.
So he's calculating it the way it should be.
I was doing just quick, quick math.
So if we were to doing amending today when we're talking about this, I don't know if this bill would be the place to do it or whether we had one bill which dealt with adequacy that, as you recall, was the differentiated aid for special education, where we upped the ante by $20 million with the three weighted categories.
That would be a place where if we wanted to modify base adequacy to reflect what the governor is suggesting, we would do it there.
But we've already executed.
But we've already executed, I'm saying.
And we don't have it.
That's right.
But at the same time, Rick, 540, because it does spell out the special education aid, even if the number were to change from a policy position, we're giving finance a good policy direction that I think is consistent with what the governor said, that he retains a special education factor in the adequacy calculation.
Yes.
And I think there's also other backup information for us conveying that.
And the last two finance study reports, one Republican and one Democrat in those years, there is recommendations in both that the base be increased.
The 2018, yes, it was increased, but margin marginally it doesn't mean we're there representative pattern now um i've really actually been hoping for a flow chart so that us new people to the budget could actually see where these things work could you maybe tell me where 529 fits in exactly on the flow chart because Because if my understanding is correct, it's an additional to the funding formula that we already have.
That's one of the issues which I think we need to discuss here.
And I think the governor did indicate that in this very convoluted formula we have, we have had in this last several years three sets of grants.
We've had physical capacity disparity aid, which if you go back a couple of years, you're going to see it there.
We had relief grant and we have extraordinary needs grant.
One is $17.5 million.
That's the relief relief and the extraordinary needs is 14.2 i believe something such that and drops down to nine point something in the second year there are too many of these such things built upon not the same topic but the same purpose same outcome we're trying to do is help the towns which don't have the revenue to accomplish what they need to do pursuant to adequacy.
Should we be saying that, and I think the governor did say it, where he, in his presentation, he's relying on one of those grants now.
As we boil down the stabilization in his new formula, which is not the amount that we have in stabilization right now, you also beef up every year 50% of the Extraordinary Needs Grant.
And there's no mention of the relief grant or the fiscal capacity.
But the amount of funding that's going to schools is a whole lot more than now.
Yes.
Yeah.
And, you know, from a, you know, size of the apple sort of thing, the $100 million that 529 distributes in each of those years is in the same, you know, park as what the governor said yesterday and the governor presented again this morning.
A very interesting thing, and I think I talked with, and we're being informal, right?
Yes, we are.
So I talked with Rick and Mel about this during the...
I didn't know you were going to do that well let's keep it I wrap yeah so let's keep it and we're an exec session you know and screaming and talked with um with um well then I'll use this name talked with um uh Bill Ardinger who the the governor mentioned and I texted Bill a picture of the slide from the thing.
And I said, wow, this looks a lot like House Bill 1680, which is something that we offered a couple of years ago.
Bill texted me right back.
Wow, that does look a lot like House Bill 1680.
So Bill served on the School Funding Commission back in 2020 with Representative Ladd, Myler, Kessgaden, myself.
And Bill Ardinger was also the governor's appointment to that commission.
And one of the things that came out of that work was House Bill 1680, which does a lot of what this looks a lot like this, including eliminating the stabilization grants and having a hold harmless in it.
All these things, I think, are probably going to be beyond what we're going to be able to do with 529 this afternoon.
Because House Bill 16, I mean, unlike 529, which is a one-page bill and pretty straightforward, House Bill 1680 is more like a 30-page bill and and gets into a whole lot of um areas that i think are beyond what we're going to be able to do this afternoon but um representative cordelli yeah just um in our presentation over at doe we we had a finance presentation.
On page six of that presentation, there was another flow chart of that that shows the relief aid grant, the extraordinary needs grant, the stabilization grant.
And in 529, there's another new category.
And I think that in a lot of our discussions, we've talked about that those three or four have to be consolidated.
They're all related.
I agree.
When the relief grant was put into the current state budget, that's how it was introduced.
Is that a grant that comes out with the end of this fiscal year?
If only I had a law book in front of me.
Well, by 2024, it's out.
In the biennium we're working towards, it would not be in, according to the governor, it wouldn't be in his proposal.
Right, right.
But does it sunset at the end of this?
I didn't think so.
So that was in there as an ongoing?
It's my impression it's there.
So just a thought for consideration.
Would some of those things phasing out grants or not phasing out, terminating a grant like the relief grant, do we want to do that in 529 or just leave that to finance as they pull all the numbers together?
I don't think we have time to do that.
Well, you know, if we don't have time, but I support eliminating a grant.
Yeah.
It's just too convoluted.
Here's what I found.
That's good you found.
So, no, and I agree, Rick, because I think 529 is directed to the same purposes of those other two grants.
Yes, it is.
So whether you call it 529, extraordinary needs of relief, you know.
Yes.
I mean, it wouldn't be possible, I think, that there's a lot here that on this specific point that we're talking about, that when it gets to finance and we're there to testify to finance that we could make that point that you were just making as far as what needs to be eliminated, etc., from the results of our conversation here on 529.
Can't that be done in front of finance?
Oh, yes, it can.
My only concern is that I don't want to appear that this committee is infatuated with everything within the governor's proposal until we've seen the spreadsheets, until we know that as you're dropping off the stabilization, the amount, this 80 plus that he's talking about a new stabilization, not the 150 million plus we have now.
And so as that drops off, the extraordinary needs grant increases each year by 50% of what you receive.
I want to make sure that the amount that's dropping off and what you receive somewhat parallels you.
From what I understand, talking with people informally right now, there's going to be those districts which are going to still need some kind of a hold harmless to make this work.
Understand that back in 2010, we didn't have stabilization.
We had hold harmless, and the hold harmless at that point in time was about $27 million total for the entire state.
That's because we had different components within that budgeting process called fiscal capacity disparity aid and how we allocated out dollars based upon free and reduced.
There was larger sums provided the districts which were hurting, like Manchester collected a whole bundle because they would get twice the base adequacy amount.
So we need to see the spreadsheets, what I'm saying.
So, Rick, we do have one spreadsheet that reflects what 529 does.
I want to make sure everybody's got that.
And if you want me to walk through the amendment that I just passed out.
Can you walk through this sheet that you've come out?
Yeah, yeah.
First, should I proceed and send the 272 change down to OLS for a quick draft?
Absolutely.
Okay.
Well, thanks.
Thanks, Len.
Thanks.
And thanks, Representative Cordelia, Representative Vlad.
So the first part of the amendment, titled Amendment Number 1 to 5 529 corrects three technical errors that were in between lines 14 and 22 of the original bill and so um so the first technical correction is um I just want to make sure, would be on line 20 of the bill.
and I'm sorry, would be on line 17 on the bill.
And it replaces the words times the ADMR.
Is everybody on 529, line 17?
All right.
Replaces times the ADMR with per pupil in the municipalities ADMR, and that's taken out of the language that we had the last time we had fiscal capacity disparity aid.
It just makes it very, very clear what municipalities would receive.
The second correction is just a couple lines down where it doesn't have the ADM multiplier in there, so they'd receive, you know, between $2,000 and $0, and that's it, not times the ADMR.
So we added that per pupil in the municipalities ADMR because you receive that number for every student that you have enrolled in that school.
And then the third technical correction is in subparagraph C, where we talk about equalized valuation.
It's equalized valuation per pupil, just like it is in A and B, or equalized valuation per ADMR of $1.6 million, so we'll receive no fiscal capacity disparity aid.
So, obviously, equalized valuation and equalized valuation per ADMR are really different.
And so any questions with the technical corrections?
Okay, I have some questions regarding just some clarification.
Back in 2018, we had a similar type proposal.
And the proposal used these figures.
And just would you please explain why these figures are no longer used today?
Okay, sure.
Those communities whose equalized valuation is at or below $660,000 would receive an additional $2,500 per student.
And that seems to be a little higher than what we have with the $2,000 would receive an additional $2,500 per student, and that seems to be a little higher than what we have with the $2,000.
The grant amount per pupil would be linearly reduced in relation to equalized property value per pupil to the minimum per pupil grant amount of $1,000 for a committee that has $1,000 in equalized property value.
So we've changed the property valuation that we're having this apply to based upon inflation, I would assume.
That's correct.
Property value.
Well, there's a couple things I've got.
So I think what you're looking at, Rick, is actually an older version of House Bill 709.
I'm just looking at the recommendations.
These are the recommendations that came out of the 2018 task force.
Yeah, so back in 2018, there actually were municipalities that had equalized valuations in the neighborhood of $350,000 per pupil, equalized valuation per pupil of about $350,000.
Now there's none that I think the lowest is just a little bit below $600,000 per pupil.
So that's why we updated the floor from $350,000 to $600,000.
And we updated the max to 1.6 million, which is just about right at the average equalized value per pupil in the state.
And so 529 is directed for fiscal capacity on a sliding scale, just like like what Representative Ladd said, for districts that have the lowest equalized valuation per pupil of $600,000 will receive $2,000 per pupil in the ADMR.
And that goes all the way down to receiving $0 per pupil in the ADMR when you get to an equalized valuation per pupil of $1.6 million.
dollars.
So it's a $600,000 to $1.6 million.
So it's a million dollars in valuation on that linear slide, which results in how the 0.0020 cents for each dollar difference, that gets you from 2,000 to zero, over a million chunks.
So forgetting the dollar figures, this is really not a change in policy from what we have.
Just updated numbers.
These are updated numbers.
It's not a change in policy.
Representative Dry?
Yeah.
Yeah, we got that too.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Representative Luno, this is three pieces of math in B there.
You find the difference between the ADMR and 16, 1,600,000, right?
Then you multiply that by 0.002, and then you multiply per pupil in their ADMR.
That's exactly correct.
Thank you.
Why don't you go on with.
Okay.
And then the bill adds three new, well, three new sections.
Section, well, section two of the bill remains.
Section two of the existing bill, I think, defines what equalized valuation per no, no, sorry.
Section 2 of the bill is the and that remains is making sure that these two grants, the fiscal capacity disparity grant and the free and reduced price lunch grant are calculated as part of the education grant going out to municipalities.
And so Section 2 modifies 198, colon 41, which is where that grant is calculated.
And then back to the amendment, new Section 3 is an accountability section that is taken verbatim from Senate Bill 420.
Did I get the number right?
The Extraordinary Needs Grant, Senate Bill 420 from last year, which got that language from the 2018 Umberger Study Committee.
And it just requires the schools receiving that grant to provide a plan on how money was used and then provide also information to the department on how successful the use of that grant was.
It also adds a floor of $50,000 so that school districts that are receiving very small grants don't have to do more paperwork than the grant is worth.
And I think we included that at the department's request in the Extraordinary Eads Grant statute this year.
So that's Section 3.
Section 4 is language that was provided, and I forget, it was either provided by legislative services or from the Legislative Budget Office on if schools were to receive additional funds from the state that went beyond what they were notified of back in October of the preceding year.
So obviously school districts have gone through their budget processes.
Budget committees have gone through their budget processes.
They all, most of them meet in March and approve their budgets.
Tax rates don't get set until the fall, the next, this fall.
But if this were to become law, the Department of Education would then send out a revised notice to all schools saying, you know, schools that fell into these grant categories would be receiving additional money.
That would obviously factor into either the district's budget or into the district's tax calculation.
And Section 4 simply allows districts to do that by being able to receive unanticipated funds that flow through the Education Trust Fund.
And then Section 5 says the act begins July 1st, 2023.
So that's the first day of our upcoming state budget.
And these provisions would apply to both years of the state budget.
Questions for the discussion from the committee?
Now, I did hear the governor suggest that when the state provides grants to fiscal capacity disparity grants to schools that, you know, and he said it in, I think, a very respectful way that it could be used how the districts want to use it, whether that's for tax reduction or to spend on new programs, that it would be up to the school district to do that.
Section 3, because it's an accountability section, it sounded like the governor would leave it up to us whether Section 3 should be in there or not.
That's what it sounded like to me.
Yeah, and this is the rubbing point on part of this.
Is the money unrestricted, like we do with adequacy and all that, or is it restricted to certain purposes which are defined elsewhere in law or within law here?
And then if it's unrestricted, then there would be no accountability section.
Now, getting into political reality right now, that I have the feeling it's going to be very difficult getting anything through finance that does not have an accountability or something written in.
This accountability, it didn't just date from the 2018 Umburger Report.
It goes back and comes out of the 2009 report when we had, you know, that we built this formula, basically.
And what's her name was of the chair, Senator Estabrook.
And they had an accountability measure in there too at that point in time.
It's very broad in nature.
I don't think it necessarily said a report had to be provided, but the money could be used for these type of purposes.
There's a wide open field of educational purposes.
So I guess that's where we are.
Do we want to have accountability in there or not?
Is it unrestricted?
Representative Kiskadden?
Just to add on accountability, I mean, I find if you add an accountability piece, but wouldn't we add the same accountability to the funding for a public charter if they're both?
I mean, it sounded like we're trying to assimilate a similar funding amount for both groups, and we should treat them all as public school students, correct?
And wouldn't we have some sort of accountability if we're doing it for one?
Why aren't we doing it for the other?
It can be a little different because the charter is different.
And it would be easier if we didn't have a specific amount of items or ways to spend it.
Because some schools will need that money to replace stabilization fund just to meet minimum standards so it's easier if it's open-ended but if you're going to go accountability for one i don't understand why you wouldn't go accountability for all publics yep let me just say one thing here now everybody understands what part of the funding formula we're dealing with.
If it's space adequacy and differentiated aid, those are unrestricted dollars.
You use them, Mr.
Superintendent and school board, any way you so desire.
Anything outside of that, though, is called a grant, a categorical type money coming in, which it's not, that is sort of different than Claremont and Londonderry, prescribed that every child gets X number of dollars or the same treatment, regardless of the community you come from, whether it's a property poor or a property wealthy community.
So I'd have to look at those extra dollars which are received by the charter.
Is that a grant, or is that part of the formula?
Is it called a grant, or is it just, say, that's part of their funding allocation per pupil?
I don't know.
So, Rick, one of theor, Mr.
Chair, sorry.
One of theI don't want theI don't want, yes, Representative Woodcock to Thank you.
Yeah, so Rick, you know, one of the, or Mr.
Chair, sorry, one of the, I don't want the Gov, I don't want, yes, Representative Woodcock to, yeah.
So the Governor did, obviously, shows the Extraordinary Needs Grant in here, in the Phase 3 line on his proposal, and that does have an accountability section in there.
If this were to essentially replace the Extraordinary Needs Grant, which I think it could do when it got to finance, then you can sort of drop it in the way it is now rather than have to add an accountability section or do anything to, I mean, it really does look a lot like the Extraordinary Needs Grant, you know, with additional dollars behind it, as the governor has suggested.
So, you know, and I think what Representative Vlad and Myler were also suggesting that getting this over to finance, obviously through the floor, onto the floor, and then to finance.
These bills, House Bill 529, will never be a standalone.
It's a standalone bill here, but it gets treated in the budget process.
It will become HB2.
It'll be an HB2.
Something will be HB2.
And this bill will eventually be ITL'd.
That's right, exactly.
This never leaves finance.
All the bills we send will be ITL'd.
So the important thing from a policy position isn't so  the important policy position is to get something to finance.
Then they can do with it, do something with it, because they're not the policy committee, the finance committee.
And so we're basically saying, and I think it's consistent with what the governor has laid out, that we need to be directing more state dollars to where they're needed most um you know um you know communities with low valuation low property valuations high property tax taxes and uh and less ability to raise the funds that they need to operate a school district in a way that so many other school districts are able to do have access to those resources.
Representative Cordelli?
Thank you.
I think that this process is more in line with what we've all said should happen, in that we will sit down with finance.
But also, we're establishing policy, and finance will then establish finance.
And all too often in the past, we've seen finance wanting to dabble in policy as well, which some of us objected to from time to time.
So I think that this will forestall that type of thing happening this go-round.
I'd like to add in, too, that this legislation may be directed to, is directed to those towns and communities which really need this support.
But the governor also presented yesterday and today over $170 million, which would be going to all schools.
There was $150 million when he added the extra $1,000 on the base adequacy.
That goes to every student.
He added in that there would be another $20 million added into F&R.
That's in differentiated aid.
That goes to every school that has free and reduced qualifying students.
We added in another $20 million for weighted formula in special education.
So what we're doing is we're doing exactly what all the reports have said in the past.
We're directing the resources not just to those that can't make it due to various reasons, but we're also complying with constitutional law, our decisions, the court decisions, that we're directing monies to all students.
And I think this is, there's a lot of reasoning why this stuff's happening.
You know, it might be a result of Conval and the other suit we have going on with Mr.
Volensky.
But I'd like to look at it further than that.
I think this is something we all recognize, as Representative Cordelli and Representative Luno have just mentioned.
It's something that's going to benefit all students in this state.
And it's going to, we have not changed basically that base adequacy formula ever, other than the CPI adjustment.
And we know that the cost of all those categories went.
And this is the difference between what we're doing now and what the commission report was.
The commission report was built on performance based on the end.
This is still staying with the inputs that, in base adequacy, here's the expectations that we have to have an adequate education.
You have to have a teacher, you have to have a specialist or a librarian, you have to this, this, this, maintenance and all that, transportation.
That's all built in base adequacy.
And we know that the minimal amount of money being paid for transportation in base adequacy at, what, is it 300 bucks a pupil or something such as that, can't be much more than that.
Doesn't pay the way for what the actual costs are in the district.
So we need to address base adequacy as well as what we're doing right here.
And that's being done through the governor's budget.
Representative Cascaden.
Is there any reaction to the fact that the governor was taking the category out of a dollar amount for students who are reading, you know, who are not proficient at reading at grade three?
That's just curious.
That's been a recommendation of every study we've had.
I know.
In the last several years.
That's only, what, a couple million bucks?
It's not a whole lot.
It's not much.
I'd rather see the money.
1.7, and it's an area that I've advocated taking out of the budget.
I think it's money that's directed in the wrong way.
There's absolutely no accountability for that one at all.
Right, and I was curious.
And so you have the Umberger Report, and the commission that Ripson-Meiler chaired also recommended that same end, that this is one of those areas that needs to go bye-bye.
And it was a political decision to put it in initially.
That's how we got some of these bills.
We agreed to a person that wanted to have poor reading.
We put it into this bill to get the bill passed years ago.
Yes, Representative Myler.
And I think the governor's increases in his proposal areas of increase was taking into account the reduction of that money.
So that there's additional money, even though you take that out, there's additional money that's going into Phil Vencema.
Pardon me?
Net gain.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's a net gain.
Thank you.
There's additional money that's going in the field.
That's not.
That's not me.
Yeah.
It's in that game.
Any kind of a gain is helpful.
Representative Dry, did you have your hand up?
Yes, I did.
Thanks.
So did we solve the problem of whether accountability would allow us to do, should we turn money in lieu of taxes?
Can we write that into it?
I mean, I know this is verbatim from someplace else, but is it editable?
What we have here is the accountability, the same accountability we have in Extraordinary Needs Grant.
And we had this discussion, as we recall, if it's less than $50,000, it's unrestricted money.
Okay.
If it's more, it's the way things, if this is used for what the governor's proposing and what the governor's proposing becomes law, I'm sure this will be addressed and maybe tweaked or changed somewhat.
It's not something we have to do today.
Right.
I think by keeping the language which we have in Extraordinary Needs Grant right now, which this is, I think it's wise to do that for many reasons.
Okay.
Yes, Representative now.
I still I'm just looking for some clarification to make sure I have this 100% correct.
So.
529 with the additional aid grants that fits in right here.
Am I correct?
OK, and.
with the changes that we think the governor is going to have with the new amount amounts of money, do we need 529?
Do we need this additional aid grant?
Okay, I just want to make sure because I try to figure out what, as things go up, what's coming down.
Yeah.
So the Extraordinary Needs Grant is, is, um, yeah, right, right.
Okay.
Yeah.
Necessary.
It sounds like we're all on that page.
Okay.
The Extraordinary Needs Grant was introduced by Senator Hennessey last year.
Yeah.
Out of Littleton?
Representative Damon?
No.
Thank you.
Would it be correct to assume that that ending statement in the new Section 3 of the amendment about you don't have to do the accountability plan if the grant award is less than $50,000.
Would it be correct to think that there won't be very many that are less than $50,000?
I think that's to be seen.
I have not seen a spreadsheet.
Right.
That's what we're up against right now.
There are a lot.
There are a lot that are less than $50,000?
And we saw that with yeah yeah we saw that with extraordinary needs grant too is as you taper down to the um getting zero there's a lot of um of districts that are just getting very marginal amounts okay and and there's nothing there's nothing wrong with marginal amounts i mean this is this is definitely based on need uh but but we you know, you don't want the paperwork burden to be.
Right, right.
I understand the purpose of it.
I was just trying to understand the incidents.
And I think the other thing that the governor mentioned today, there needs to be an effort for consolidation of our districts.
The issue that we have some school districts are getting so small and we have statutory language saying you will provide this, this, this, and this, and that's why the per pupil costs keep going up so high.
They have to provide all the aspects of curriculum and instruction that they are required to.
It's cost prohibitive, but we are now funding that if we could consolidate representative cascada if you could consolidate with uh gorham it'd be a miracle up there well we've been working on it i don't know 45 50 years it hasn't happened yet but i know it there's always in meeting together.
Yeah.
And it always seems like the services that are provided are always one-sided because we're always opening our whatever we have to offer, but it's not always reciprocated.
But, yeah, that's a tough thing.
But people say, taxpayers say, why not?
Yeah.
We'll see.
That is the key.
That's where you can get some of the efficiencies if we go into this.
That's critical.
That will help us with these funding formulas.
If you look at the data throughout the country, our administrative costs in the state of New Hampshire are fourth highest in the country because we have so many small districts, which by law have to have that administrative support.
Representative Damon.
So just to add support to that, in the nine-town district that I represent, well, one city, eight towns, there are seven different school districts.
I mean, it's nuts.
All these little individual towns have their own school district.
It's not cost effective.
It seems like we could have some learning from Vermont.
I mean, they mandated consolidation, have been working on that for the last five years.
I have mixed results on that, though.
There are mixed results.
Yes.
If you were to talk to the fellow who was superintendent of the year here back a little bit and went over and worked in Orange County in Vermont, he said the administrative costs are going the other direction.
That's costing more.
If you look at consolidation over in the state of Maine when they went after consolidation, one school district consolidated, and that was Rumford, Mexico, right on either side of the Anderskoggin River, and they should have been one all along, seeing the population of the town has gone down.
Rumford used to have the highest per capita income in the state of Maine when the old Oxford Paper Company was there, and Bo boise cascade now now it's it's a ghost town basically and and they did consolidate only one state and one town consolidated so consolidation is a tough thing it's almost like you got it i don't know what you got to mandate it or get up there and beat them over the head, but they don't want to do it.
It's all local control.
Mr.
Chair, it seems like there are some interesting ramifications for the amount of school districts we now want to remove themselves from cooperative school districts.
I was just talking to the New Hampshire School Boards Association about that.
How many have grown since the short time we've been here, Barrett?
Sure, come on up.
Well, he gave a number today, which was pretty amazing to me.
Thank you, Chairman Ladd, members of the Committee Bear Christina School Boards Association.
Let's not mistake cooperative school districts for school administrative units, the SAUs.
I started at NHSBA in 2005.
There were, I believe, 84 SAUs at the time, your central offices.
We're up to, I think, 106 now, so one more year.
So that is a new superintendent.
Some of those are part-time superintendents that will cover a couple different small districts, but that's still more services by law that that SAU has to provide your special ed services, your central office, your business manager, your superintendent.
And the whole issue with the co-ops is a whole other issue.
Sure.
So when I started in 2005, I believe there were 84, perhaps 85 SAUs, and now we're up to, I believe, it's 106.
So 20 more than we had 17 years ago.
Yes, Representative Cornell.
Garrett, how do they increase?
So the SAU withdrawal process is very simple.
If we have three towns and a multi-district SAU, all you have to do is you create a study committee per statute.
There's statutory language to do that.
The issue goes on the warrant.
It's voted on to initiate the withdrawal study.
You have to go through six months of studying and the numbers and how you're going to provide the services, the special ed and the business services.
I believe the Department of Education, I'm sorry, the State Board reviews it without, they don't decide whether it's a good idea or a bad idea.
They just make sure that all the boxes have been checked, that the statute requires be within the SAU withdrawal plan, and then it goes to the voters only within the town that is looking to withdraw.
It doesn't go out SAU-wide.
So that town controls its ability of whether or not that school district controls its ability of whether or not they want to withdraw.
My experience, when I, so again, going back almost 17, 18 years now, I noticed that it was often the property rich town that was initially deciding to leave and withdraw, figuring we don't, we don't, we have the money, we don't need to share the administrative costs with the other neighboring districts.
I've also seen sort of the inverse happening now, where it's perhaps the smaller property poor district, when I say now maybe the last 10 years, the smaller property poor district that is withdrawing, saying we're paying perhaps a third of the sau office budget but we're only getting maybe 20 of the services so we'll bear we'll eat the cost but we know it's our superintendent answerable to us our business manager answerable to us we're not sharing services and that's a that's a cost that's a local that's a local decision if they if it costs more but they're getting full services, that's the prerogative of the voters in that community.
Yep.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
So we've gone through the possible amendment here.
This is amendment number one.
Was there a three or four um i i have a another version of of this without the accountability section okay um that uh i i don't know if we really need to talk about that and um and that's all i have okay okay and we've already exact 540 which i think sends over a good policy change in the adequacy thing, and I just received the amendments back from OLS.
Okay.
I'm just reviewing it right now.
Okay, good.
And I'll make copies of here.
Mine's upstairs and copy.
Okay, great, great.
Okay, so what we're going to do is, if there's any more discussion, we can have that.
If not, let's just take a short break until we get those amendments down here.
Thank you.
We should all have several amendments in front of us so on 272 you need to have the amendment 0223 and on 520 need you need amendment that's 0544 so looks like we're all good that way By the way, somebody just asked, how do you keep your memory there?
I'll tell you the key is a tablespoon of maple syrup every morning.
Well, yeah, there was a study done that in Vermont, of course.
Pardon me?
And take vitamin B.
Okay.
So we're going to take up 529 first, and I look to Representative Luna for a motion, please.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Chair.
I move it ought to pass on House Bill 529.
Is there a second?
Second.
Okay, there is a motion made by Representative Leno and seconded by Representative Myler.
OTP on 0544H.
Hold on.
I put the bill on the table and now I'll put the, or not on the table, but I'll put the, offered a motion on the bill and I'll offer a motion about to pass on amendment 0544H to House Bill 529 okay and is there a second on that I'll second it okay so Representative Luno put forth 529 HB 529 the bill is introduced and that was second by Representative Meiler.
Representative Luno, you're recognized for discussion or an amendment.
Thanks.
Thanks very much.
Amendment 544 is the amendment that we've just been talking about that makes technical corrections to the fiscal capacity disparity grant in section 1.
It makes no changes in section 2, which is how the grant is calculated by the Department of Education.
It adds a new section 3 for accountability of grants.
It adds a new Section 4 which applies to school districts for FY 2024 so that they can, you know, should this all pass and go into a budget or whatever, they'd be able to actually use the money.
And Section 5, which is the effective date of July 1, 2023, which is the first day of the new state budget.
Further discussion?
Not seeing any.
Madam Clerk, would you please call the roll on the amendment?
Vice Chairman Cordelli?
Yes.
Representative Lekas?
Representative Ford?
Yes.
Representative Belcher?
Representative Dry?
Yes.
Representative McDonnell?
Representative Noble?
Yes.
Representative Petternell?
Representative Cortiello?
Yes.
Representative McDonald.
Representative Noble.
Yes.
Representative Pedernal.
Representative Cortiello.
Yes.
Representative Myler.
Representative Cornell.
Yes.
Representative Lane.
Representative Luna.
Yes.
Representative Ellison.
Representative Woodcock.
Yes.
Representative Hall.
Representative Balboni.
Yes.
Representative Cascadon.
Representative Damon.
Yes.
Chairman Latt.
20 a's.
Zero nays.
I'm going to hand the gavel over to Representative Cordelli now.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
The next would be a motion on the...
Well, we need to have a motion.
Yeah, that's right.
Yeah, I'm making a motion.
Right.
Yeah.
And so I call on Chairman Ladd for that motion.
I'd like to move HB 529 as amended with 0544H.
Second anyone?
I'll second that.
Thank you.
Discussion?
I have no discussion.
No further discussion from the committee?
Great.
Madam Chair?
Madam Clerk?
that's okay we'll go back to that mental health bill vice chairman cordelli We'll go back to that mental health bill.
Vice Chairman Cordelli.
Yes.
Representative Lekas.
Representative Ford.
Yes.
Representative Belcher.
Representative Dry.
Yes.
Representative McDonnell.
Representative Noble.
Yes.
Representative Petternell.
Representative Cordello.
Yes.
Representative Myler.
Representative Noble.
Yes.
Representative Petternell.
Representative Quartiello.
Yes.
Representative Myler.
Representative Cornell.
Yes.
Representative Lane.
Representative Luna.
Yes.
Representative Ellison.
Representative Woodcock.
Yes.
Representative Hall.
Representative Balboni.
Yes.
Representative Cascadden.
Representative Damon.
Yes.
Chairman Latt.
20 A's, 0 A's.
Okay.
None of these bills can go, of course, on consent because they're all finance bills.
The next bill is 272, and I look to Representative Cordelli to make a motion, please.
Yes, I would like to move on to pass, and I have an amendment to offer after that.
Is there a second?
Second.
Who said that?
Thank you.
Representative McDonald.
Representative Cordelli, do you have a discussion or an amendment?
I have an amendment to offer.
And yes, thank you.
It's amendment23-0223H.
Is there a second?
Second.
Representative Belcher?
Representative Cordelli?
Thank you.
This, as we discussed earlier, just changes the amount, drops it by approximately $500 per student.
Further discussion?
Not seeing any?
Any further discussion from the committee?
Madam Clerk, when you're ready, we're ready.
The bill, this is on the amendment now.
Ought to pass on Amendment 274HB 272-022H3H.
Vice Chairman Cordelli.
Yes.
Representative Lekas.
Representative Ford.
Yes.
Representative Elcher.
Representative Dry.
Yes.
Representative McDonnell.
Representative Noble.
Yes.
Representative Petternell.
Representative Cortella.
Yes.
Representative Myler.
Representative Cornell.
Yes.
Representative Lane.
Representative Luna.
Yes.
Representative Ellison.
Representative Woodcock.
No.
Representative Hall.
Yes.
Representative Balboni.
Representative Cass Gabbin.
No.
Representative Damon.
Yes.
Chairmani.
Representative Cass Gavin.
No.
Representative Damon.
Yes.
Chairman that yes.
18 years to nays.
Thank you.
Right.
Yes, you're recognized.
Thank you, Mr Chairman.
I would would like to move, ought to pass as amended with Amendment 0223H.
Is there a second?
Second.
Thank you, Representative McDonald.
Further discussion, Representative Cordelli?
None.
Representative McDonald?
Communication with the, yes, Representative Myler.
Yes.
I plan to vote on this, and I want to make a statement.
This is really the first time that I voted for an increase to charter schools.
And the reason why I'm doing this is because I've watched the charter schools develop over the years.
I'm still very concerned about the oversight of charter schools.
I think there are some major issues that still need to be addressed.
We've had concerns that have been exhibited on a regular basis before the State Board of Education regarding governance of the charter schools.
I'm concerned about that.
Although even with those questions, I've come to the conclusion that at least at this point in time, particularly as I look at the surplus that's in the education trust fund, because I've always been concerned about funding going to public schools directly, even though that charters are public schools.
And so this is, for me, is a major change in my vote on this particular issue, and I plan to vote yes.
Further discussion, Representative Cordelli?
Yes, I just want to follow up on that in that I had checked with Tal Baer from the Department of Education in relation to charter schools on the number of closures.
And since 2005, there have been nine closures, and all are the result of enrollment and subsequent financial challenges, per his email.
Further discussion?
Representative Kiskadden?
I support the work that the charters are doing because I've seen some successful ones.
I think they deserve the increase in the funding.
Again, my concern is the accountability.
That's what I struggle with.
What's the achievement progress?
What's the graduation rate?
I haven't been able to find any of that data.
And from what I could see, there is a template of a plan that they have to fill out for the Department of Ed based on objectives.
But it definitely doesn't rise to the level of the public school data reports, and it doesn't necessarily have to.
But there should be some caveat of an accountability that would help reinforce the public's trust in a charter school even.
Thank you.
And I'd like to just dovetail on that a little bit.
Representative Cascadden, you and I have a charter school up in Littleton.
That's an exceptional organization and works very cooperatively with the superintendents in those school districts in which kids come to it from.
And I think we have some models out there that are very, very successful, and working with students which are really benefiting from being in that environment.
In fact, the district item has seats allocated to it for that charter school, as I'm sure that you do over there to Berlin.
And so there are some really, really exceptional charter schools out there that are doing this, and I feel there really is a place for them, and this will help them even succeed and do some things we may be asking them to be accountable for.
Thank you.
Yes, Representative Luno.
Yeah, thank you very much, Mr.
Chair, and I'm not trying to take away your last word on this so so but but I wanted to also indicate as did Representative Myler this will be the first time that I'm supporting an increased grant to charter schools and and I think it's it's really for two there's two reasons why I'm supporting this one of them is is I think it's fair they haven't had an increase to their Thank you.
And I think it's really for two reasons why I'm supporting this.
One of them is I think it's fair.
They haven't had an increase to their grant in five years, and we've certainly seen a lot happen over the last five years in terms of increased costs, whether that's staffing, whether it's materials or rent.
And I think it's fair uh number two is um is i would like to see uh charter schools have more oversight and and accountability but it's hard to ask for accountability when you're not funding them in a fair way that allows them to be accountable to do a to do a a good job with with uh with strong outcomes and i'm not saying that that charter schools don't do a good job with strong outcomes.
And I'm not saying that charter schools don't do a good job and don't have strong outcomes, because many clearly do.
But when you're not funding them, when you're having them gasp for air, same with public school districts.
When they're gasping for air, it's hard to hold them accountable.
so I think as we've done in 529 and as we're hoping to do with charters, to be able to hold them accountable, I think we've got to start with making sure that we're accountable.
Thank you.
Representative Pettner.
I would just like to comment on the accountability and say that if the greatest measure of accountability is that the parents continue to send their children there.
And if the parents didn't think their children were getting good results, then they would put them back in the public schools.
Representative Cascadden.
I was just thinking of a simple thing that would work as accountability is, you know, how many students in each charter school is reading at grade level, say by third grade?
I mean, they should, even if it's a K to four, K to five, shouldn't they be able to produce that no matter what tool they use?
And if they have a high school component, how many kids do they graduate every year?
Those are simple data points, aren't they?
I mean, what do you think?
I think that my response to that is that I think we can get the data points on the graduation in terms of some charter schools are built around students maybe have IEPs, and I would kind of be cautious in stating that, because even for those that have IEPs in the regular public schools, when it comes to the statewide assessment, we accommodate them in that with an alternative assessment.
Or in some, they don't even take it because it's just written in the IEP.
And they may even have a full year program.
They may have a program going through the summertime as well.
So there are some extenuating circumstances.
I believe that the charter schools all do have accountability through the statewide assessment.
They take that assessment.
And so that assessment score is the same one that comes out.
So we can get a hold of that information, and that's easy for us to look at.
And if we see something like we've been seeing with the underperformance in mathematics throughout the state with students from every walk of life just about, then we've got to step in and say, okay, how can we help?
How can we help professional training?
how can we help how can we help professional training how can we help through higher education helping the teachers how can we help families because we're going through so many unique situations in our society today that many kids walk home and there is nobody home and and so you know rather rather than doing that reading that they should be doing or hearing somebody read to them, like I was reading just the other night for my youngster in the house, Blueberries for Sal by McCluskey, they don't get that opportunity.
And so they'd rather Xbox it, even if they have the Xbox.
So I think we got to be cautious, but they do take the statewide assessment so we can get the information.
Yes.
So do you think it would, to me, I mean, these are public schools, and I think part of our messaging when we develop this is to get public support to see, see here's another opportunity for kids, and maybe some type of line in there that says they're accountable through the New Hampshire state assessment system, period.
Well, they are accountable.
Right, but the public may not know that.
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
So maybe we just have to work with DOE to making that, you know, knowledgeable rather than doing it through legislation.
We make so much legislation, so many rules that it's like the government was saying.
I agree with you.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Representative Damon.
And I love the blueberries for Sal book.
I just have to say that.
So I agree that it's appropriate for charter schools to have more funding after five years without any change.
But I significantly share the concerns about accountability and oversight.
When charter schools were enacted into law in 1996, so quite a while ago, the Joint Legislative Oversight Committee was established in that original law.
Representative Tanner left me a chart of the file on the meetings of the Legislative Oversight Committee going back to 1996.
In 2011, there were five meetings, and there was a report that came out of that oversight committee.
In 2012, there were two meetings.
There was one meeting per year in each year from 2013 to 2016, and there have been no meetings since then.
There has been no reports since 2011.
So perhaps the chairs thought that we need to get action on what already exists in law is the right way to go, but it seems very concerning to me that we have an oversight committee that essentially does nothing and we hear nothing from.
Representative Lekas.
My understanding, and please correct me if I'm wrong wrong but the portal that we know about the do portal and it's on public schools aren't the charter schools in there and don't we have all this data right at our fingertips so anybody who wants to know any of that stuff isn't that there or am i mistaken it's there it's there represent woodcock thank you chairman and i'm Thank you, Chairman.
And I'm sure I hope you get the last word.
I appreciate the interest in increased funding charter schools, particularly because Conway has two legitimate school choice options for parents.
They have the charter school, obviously our newest one that focuses on outdoor ed philosophy, and as well as the Robert Frost has been there for a long time.
So I do appreciate that.
And down in Glenn's area, there's a new one coming in with a $1.1 million construction loan at the new historic site.
So the child schools are vibrant in Carroll County, and I do appreciate the fact that they give public school parents an opportunity to choose a legitimate public school.
Thank you.
Further discussion?
Representative Paul?
Thank you.
I just wanted to make sure I heard this right.
Did I hear that parents, Representative Paternell, parents have the ultimate say on whether a school or any kind of schooling, I should say, is accountable?
If the parents say it is, then that's the end of the game?
They do send their own children to the public schools and put them to any school.
Parents trust whoever they're sending their children to to be educated.
So especially with a charter school, they have the option to take their students, their children out, right?
Because they're voluntarily seeking a school outside of the public school system so if the if they aren't happy with the charter school they could easily just take their children out of the charter school and put them back in the public school so yes i would say ultimately the parents would decide whether or not the school was successful because if it wasn't suiting the needs or the students weren't meeting adequate educational improvement parents would just take them right back out in either homeschool or put them in a public school or send them somewhere else so yeah by parents having the choice they're deciding what's working best for their own children I don't agree with that at all.
Well, the bottom line is that there is accountability information available on the portal through a statewide assessment that's available.
I think that this bill is dealing with the financing.
It's not talking about all the procedures and processes associated with charter.
I think we've really escaped and gone beyond the boundaries.
And I was hoping we could keep this right on task here and look at this particular topic as we did on 5.29.
Representative Ellison.
I hope I can meet those parameters with this question.
Thank you.
I, too, am going to vote for the bill.
So I appreciate the rationale that's been offered for that.
I, too, am sort of concerned about the accountability.
The one thing on the accountability that seems to me to be unacceptable is the fact that the oversight committee has not met for five years.
There seems to be a complete lack of interest on this committee about the fact that that committee has not met.
And I think that's not a good way to run state government.
Thank you.
I'd like to just take a second and talk about some of these oversight committees.
There's a number of them that have worked well.
And I know that like the oversight committee on improvement and assessment, we had one meeting earlier this year, and the second one will probably be occurring.
I haven't set it up in the docket yet, but it would probably be somewhere on the time we may have off, because there's no other time in which you have to have this.
And I don't I've not ever sat on this oversight committee.
But I know that I know that it needs to act in accordance with statutory law, which says, you know, you should have a report to the, you know, the Senate, the House, the State Library, et cetera, et cetera.
So if there's evidence that it has been functioning, we need to get it going and need to get that oversight because we do have oversight in some of the other areas which we're looking at, and I think that's going to be very, very important.
In fact, one of the things on the next oversight meeting will be standards that we've oftentimes talked about, and we're watching.
So any further discussion?
Pardon me?
Patty's not watching.
You've run out of time?
Yeah.
I'll Follow up in your comment, if I may.
Who is the chair of the Charter School Oversight Committee?
See, one of the problems is I can't answer directly.
Maybe Representative Cordelli can.
I know that I thought Representative Shah was on it when she was here.
The nature of the beast here is that every two years we have elections, and then those people that were on it are gone.
Okay.
Or choose.
I don't want to be back on that.
And I've been on several things down here.
I couldn't wait to get off.
Gelcar was one.
I was on the Special Education Advisory Council.
I couldn't attend that either.
So what I wanted to be on again, but I saw Representative Cornell, you've done an excellent job.
That's a real good one that they meet often.
And so it's, I think a lot of it's because people do leave, and then some of them, for example, higher education, it switches between leadership in the Senate, leadership in here.
I understand that, Reverend Lamar.
I'm just trying to find out who is in charge.
I, if it, for example, if it's set up by the Senate, a Senate bill, the Senate has responsibility for putting their senators on it, but the senators then are the ones that are responsible for making the motion for, okay, who's going to be chair of this thing unless it's stipulated in that bill.
I'm still waiting for people from the Senate to be appointed to legislative oversight.
Okay, but going back to this committee, who's in charge?
I don't know.
How do we find that out, Reverend Roy?
Check with the Speaker's office.
You will check with Deputy Childs?
Glenn, in all due respect, I sent the Speaker several emails, to which I never had a response on any.
So let's not know that one.
I will check with Deputy Childs about that.
Appreciate it.
Thank you, sir.
Chief of Staff is one that's ultimately their responsible speaker, but they delegate that to the Chief of Staff, Deputy Chief of Staff.
Okay, we're back to 272.
And is it ought to pass as amended?
So we're at that motion.
Is there any further discussion?
Madam Clerk, would you please call the roll?
Vice Chairman Cordelli.
Yes.
Representative Lekas.
Representative Ford.
Yes.
Representative Belcher.
Representative Dry.
Yes.
Representative McDonnell.
Representative Noble.
Yes.
Representative Petternell.
Representative Corotiello.
Yes.
Representative Myler.
Representative Cornell.
Yes.
Representative Lane.
Representative Luno.
Yes.
Representative Ellison.
Representative Woodcoff.
Yes.
Representative Hall.
Representative Balboni.
Yes.
Representative Cascadon.
Representative Damon.
No.
Chairman Lidd.
Yes.
19 yays, 1 nay.
Thank you very much.
You know, I was just thinking a little bit about the chairs of all these oversights.
There's one that represents a mile around teacher shortage, and our chair was Senator Jay Kahn.
And Jay is now retired to the other side of the state, and we need to have the Senate grab a hold of that and put people onto that committee so we can continue that work.
That's one of the problems that we encounter with who's chair and all that, because we don't have a chair of that committee now.
The chair calls the meetings, and that's the Senate bill.
Yep, Representative Cascada.
Just a question.
Did you say that we would get the spreadsheets today on the breakout of 529?
That's why a number of us went in to that finance, because I was under the impression that they were going to be handed out.
They were not handed out.
Oh, they weren't.
And I don't think they're available yet.
Okay.
And they will be provided.
They're supposed to be coming out of the DOE.
Okay.
I know that Division II had a meeting this afternoon.
I don't know if they received something then or not while we've been doing this.
Okay.
But we're not sitting here until they come.
No.
In fact, we're not going to be doing any more execing today.
We're going to stop it right here and adjourn this meeting.
Are you sure?
It's early.
It's going on 20th 3.
Well, we're going to exec what we can tomorrow.
All our hearings will be completed here real shortly.
All we have left is execing, and we can accomplish that during the month of March.
Any problems with that?
We will do so.
All of our early bills are done.
All our early bills are done.
OK, we had three early bills we had today.
We exact them.
So we're good.
So, Mr.
Chair, if I could.
Yeah.
We retained HB 437, so it's still in our possession.
And I did do an amendment to it, and I was hoping that the body would take another look at that.
And we received a very important letter, I think, a couple of days ago, and I have copies of it, but if I could just read it to you.
It's to the committee.
I am writing to you in regard to my concern for New Hampshire Public Schools, current method of teaching and reading, and my support for HB 437.
I am currently a reading specialist in a Concord public school.
I have been an educator in Concord for 25 years.
In the past three years, I began a journey in learning a lot about the research that has been coming to light regarding reading and instruction.
It has been an enlightening but emotional journey.
I was taught and had previously been implementing a balanced literacy approach.
This was all I knew, and I was led to believe that it was a well-supported way of teaching children to read.
I always questioned some things in the back of my mind and was concerned that no matter how hard we taught using this method, we never saw a great shift in children's ability to read.
Our Title I students were Title I students for life.
This is not how it's supposed to be.
Our test scores also tell a story that something isn't working, but I did what I was told until now.
Now I have spent countless hours reading the research myself directly from cognitive scientists and neuroscientists.
I see that we were wrong, especially in regard to the 3-Qing system that we have been misguided.
I am extremely concerned that if we don't make a drastic change to how we approach teaching reading, it may be too late for too many children.
By implementing the 3-queuing system, we actually change the wiring in children's brains so that they were at risk for never becoming good readers.
I have seen too many of these curriculum casualties as reading specialists.
These are students that should never have needed my help if they had received proper instruction from the beginning.
You can help stop this cycle.
The items in this bill will force the hand of many schools that may try and keep one foot in balanced literacy, which will not provide the change needed.
We, public schools, need to be held accountable to all the learners entrusted to us.
We need to be sure that we are giving them the absolute possible best chance of success.
This bill can bring us one step closer to that possibility.
I, for the sake of the New Hampshire children, please pass this bill and allow those of us ready to begin a better path to do this work.
Yeah, yeah, that's the run.
Okay, we've retained that, so we have?
No.
We have the dyslexia bill.
Yeah.
Okay.
So what's the number of that bill?
377.
377, when is it?
I don't think you see that later on in the doctor.
You're hugging them.
I'm holding them all.
It wasn't an FN or anything.
I was looking for like four.
Today's Wednesday, right?
And then we're looking at we have a whole lot of we don't have 377 on here at all.
Did we act on 377?
Not yet, I don't think.
Okay, so if you're asking for us to take action on 377, it's not really on the list at all.
And that's the other bill.
And this one right here, we have retained.
So there'd be a question.
There's several questions on procedure that I have.
Go ahead.
You have a question?
No.
Oh, Reps and Alexis?
For the bills that we've retained, do we have study committees started on those so that we can be actually working on them we had several work sessions on on bills which we've now acted upon we haven't set up any subcommittees on the retained bills at this point in time no we haven't And we haven't retained that many bills compared to what we i'm sure in looking at this list here uh and i think everybody ought to be looking at this list so when we do exact we can exact quickly um there's a number of bills that are probably going to be that could end up with uh no recommendation and we know where that went yesterday um that's correct you know we're going to stop the clocks in the in the in the hall someday and just have to stay there i guess and finish this stuff but um i i think what we need to do is look at this and say and i i probably need to get together with uh represent represent a miler here and find out which ones are these bills.
We just haven't had the time to sit down together.
At least I haven't.
And we have sat down quite a bit.
But we've been sitting down on the early bills and trying to develop a process there.
And I think the process has worked out wonderfully.
We got some stuff done today that first blush or first time we saw those i would have said this is not going to make it because one side or the other is going to be voting against it we voted these things out today because we looked at policy and we know there's an opportunity either on the floor but later on in finance to really address so many issues that have come, like the one you brought forward earlier today, Representative Luckett.
So I think that what we ought to do is I need to get together with leadership on the other side and find out which ones can we get through.
I'm looking at this laundry list right here.
I was looking at the time that we have available.
Now, the reports that we did today have to be in today, seeing that tomorrow we're going to have hearings.
And so I want to give them to Lindsay.
And I had to get the schedule for the next week done today also.
That's done.
So I guess that I'd rather not have to go through exact things at quarter of three here, starting out on this list.
We could be here a long time.
We could shortcut the time, maybe, if I sit down with Representative Meiler and we go through these things and say, which ones do we have, you know, folks that will go one way or the other on?
And it's always an assumption because that's not how everybody turns out.
So, you know, I can't read your minds, but Representative Cordelli.
Yeah, I was just wondering if a motion to reconsider on 437 would be a proper motion at this time.
Well, the bill has not left our possession, and I've never had a retained bill where we've had a motion for reconsideration.
I'd like to find out from the clerk whether that's allowable in our rules.
yeah before we do that if it is allowable we can you know we'll reconsider it um because you're asking for it right now we'll reconsider it um at a time that's you know if we have to properly post it we'll do that if not um because it's it's a germane amendment or do you have a germane or just or not not add anything you're right get the bill tweaking a couple of things okay yeah represent belcher and mr chairman if it requires when the time comes, having voted with a majority on that, I would make the motion to reconsider.
You don't, you can, in committee, you don't have to be in the majority or the minority.
Anybody can ask for reconsideration on any bill, regardless how you voted.
Yes, that's not the same on the floor, though.
Representative Lekas.
So I did come up with, I did get the amendment, and I have it.
It was according on the cursive writing and multiplication table bill that was, the amendment was just putting it to what we had agreed on.
And so can we do that as well?
Reconsider that to put in that amendment rather than the one that wasn't quite what we had agreed on?
It was very simple.
What was the number of that?
I can tell you in a moment.
71.
Was it 71?
Yeah.
No.
No, no, no, not 71.
It was, that's not it.
170.
170, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
NNNNNNNNNNNNNNNNNNNNNNNNNNNN want.
170.
Have we acted on that bill?
We recessed.
It's on hold, yeah.
It's on hold.
We did.
We passed the other amendment that wasn't quite what we wanted.
We OTPA'd it.
Then we had a motion to ITL, and we recessed.
At that point.
And so can we go back and reconsider and look at, or whatever we have to do to look at, the amendment that was the agreed upon amendment and take a vote on that amendment?
Let me, again, let me do some checking on that process.
Okay.
Yeah.
Because I do have it.
I did it right that day.
Any other discussion for today?
We're done.
We have about half, 15 minutes.
Yeah, I will.
Let's give us some copies of this.
Yeah.
I wonder if Tony's...
Thank you.
I'm going to swallow it.
I have my big binder on bills.
The ones we accepted, they were early bills, so we can't.
Yeah, I think that's that's got a financial.
the one deal with uh uh can't go oh right that that's got a financial that they're not no oh i want to show you something they all got Thank you.
Thank you.